well the president's son-in-law Jared
Kushner is drawing new attention for his
campaign meetings with foreign officials
CBS News has confirmed a report that
Kushner updated the foreign contacts
list on his security clearance formed
three times he added more than 100 names
after mentioning zero contacts on his
original form the top Democrat on the
Senate Intelligence Committee is asking
Kushner and Donald Trump jr. for
documents on last year's meeting with a
lawyer who said to have had ties with
the Kremlin Senator Mark Warner says he
expects Trump jr. and Kushner to testify
to Congress the president's lawyers
reportedly learned of that meeting more
than three weeks ago mr. Trump says he
first heard of it just a few days ago
the president told reporters on his
flight to Paris that healthcare is more
difficult than peace in the Middle East
this morning he focused on GOP lawmakers
tweeting after all these years of
suffering through Obamacare Republican
senators must come through as they have
promised Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill
with reaction to the newest Republican
plan to replace Obamacare Nancy good
morning good morning GOP leaders did not
get the reception they were hoping for
one Senate Republican holdout said he's
not sure whether the new bill is any
better than the original while other
holdouts said they want to wait to see
what the Congressional Budget Office
thinks of the bill next week before they
make up their minds and if they don't
come around it's unclear whether there's
a plan seat we urge every member of the
United States Senate to roll their
sleeves up and get this bill to the
President's desk and get it there soon
the White House announced its support
for the party's new health care bill
even as some GOP senators held back how
do you feel about the bill senator
Maine senator Susan Collins said she
will vote no so did Kentucky's Rand Paul
do you think the new version is better
than the old version no I think it's
worse I mean the the old version
repealed most of the Obamacare taxes
this repeals about half the Obamacare
taxes the bill uses that tax revenue to
pay for opioid addiction treatments and
it puts an additional seventy billion
into a fund to stabilize premiums on the
individual market but it does not roll
back the deep Medicaid cuts in the first
version a key sticking point for at
least half a dozen moderates at this
point the only holdout who has gone from
no to yes so far is Texas conservative
Ted Cruz the new bill includes his
proposal to let insurers offer cheaper
plans with fewer benefits I think we've
made very significant progress expanding
choices expanding options expanding
competition and reducing premiums but
his backing won't be enough to keep the
bill alive and that has even supporters
of the bill like Lindsey Graham casting
about for alternative everybody is
looking for an idea that is more
Republican and does not run into the
concept you're taking money from poor
people to give it to rich people some
moderates are mystified by the fact that
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
did not address their chief concern
Medicaid in this new version and that
has led some to speculate Jeff that
perhaps he has always known that getting
to 50 votes was a longshot and he'd
rather fail if that's what's going to
happen with a more conservative bill
than a more moderate one Nancy Cordes
thank you very much